[Music]
an unrealistic standard news submitted
by beast nice women on twitch were going
without makeup to support a fellow
streamer hello it down or what then I go
down why are you looking at me like that
I will tell you I didn't experiment
before when I was a waitress and I went
a week without wearing makeup while I
was serving my tables I made almost half
of my tip do you yeah you can do that
you can do that I don't even think
people were consciously like or my tip
or less because she's ugly or whatever I
think it's just subconsciously they just
what hey where you showed more cleavage
but then ya know try that people care
about the face nothing else it's all
about the thing it could also be that
maybe I was more energetic with makeup
on I don't know maybe you feel more
confident with me prettier with it on
yeah maybe you were just a [ __ ] that is
where I made sure to give the exact same
service a [ __ ] for I gave exact same
service how do you know sometimes girls
they got a feel from the inside out from
the inside that's where the heart is
hashtag me too
I don't think that's the v2 movement
yeah I'm just using whatever's out there
alright so this switch streamer her name
is poppy mate or like her handle
whatever poky me oh I know this dreamer
yeah I haven't watched her thing but
then like we have mutual friends oh yeah
cool yeah so she's so popular but all of
us do we all not okay I'm such an
[ __ ] I don't know I don't have
friends
what's cuz you guys are we know the
night your friends geek stuff in the
yeah in the gaming stuff and all that
but we have friends who like that stuff
I only know two streamers silent Mike
and Gina
oh we know two streamers silent Mike and
Gina
[Music]
Oh Gina all in all to nuts out of my oh
she's cute on twitch oh yeah she uh yeah
her name is cookie mingle button okay
now imagine here without makeup she
looks the same she people go wild with
me that food looks the same without I
can show you so she decided to stream
without makeup of starting her stream
without makeup and it just created this
whole like controversy wait before you
been show so have you guys seen though
the ones coming out of Asia like when
they do they take their face no oh yeah
I've seen though that's obscene
what if it stop but she's not Asian
that's like a that's like a trended
maybe she learned no I mean I mean she's
got extreme yeah oh I say I mean it's
I've seen videos where like there's
Asian boys that do it well and become a
hot beautiful woman that's true
sometimes I look at alright man rock and
I kind of want to bond him a little bit
[Music]
he watches he does watch it and then if
he sees me he's gonna try to get out and
I'm gonna be running away from it you do
when we met it you see there's a cow is
what cut mean if he's something happens
would you really be mad it's Brett my
rock yeah if I made out with them you
wouldn't be okay now you have tears
approval right I need someone to protect
me from this bug yeah did you see his
ghost thing and it he turns around in
his [ __ ] butt cheeks are hanging out
he caught me off guard cuz it was on
Facebook he's like guys there's a ghost
in my house and it just he just pops out
and Apple has boo
he won't boot and he covered his dick
with that yeah and he has a ghost thing
that just goes up to his nipples he's
like boo [ __ ] imma go and as soon as he
turned around I was like what the [ __ ] I
was I couldn't stop watching it I was
like what the [ __ ] is happening this is
my he's engaging though you get sucked
into his video he's great remember the
one when he was on a treadmill on
[ __ ] like doing [ __ ] runway [ __ ]
on a treadmill only about to see that
those are the two that really stood out
to me I like the one where his weight
lifting dude he missed it and he just
throws it and he just slides for like
like a stripper experimenting like his
science experiment
when he was doing the bubbles and she
rock his roots at all right anyway we're
talking about so much sass she tricked
me if she looks way different than that
because I looks pretty natural I bet you
she looks [ __ ] up compared to that
we're doing a story on it we all do I'm
not gonna talk straight because we all
look [ __ ] okay
no one girls without makeup look guys I
don't care I don't you [ __ ] liar what
cuz I always go cuz you're like oh
you're so beautiful and I'm not makeup
and then and then like you're such a
liar you like me with makeup you just
admitted that torture I like you with
makeup no you didn't I did no you did it
Oh hmm oh I'll still bust nuts if you
don't have makeup on but I said I like
you I miss my parents
every guy huh bust more nuts with makeup
oh you can control your nutter yeah your
nutr alright I don't care I just look at
the ass
but just has a pretty face so it's okay
she does yeah she does okay so this is
pokey man without makeup hiya
so this is how she started her stream
yeah she looks beautiful
she shot beautiful but she looks
different it just looks like a different
person yeah she just looks like her slow
do you see that's where you panic
because their eyes are some it's top
down you know you have no sight she also
didn't do her hair anything she was like
you know what I feel like it's important
that we don't always show you our selves
like really done up because it's
unrealistic women don't look like this
or like this
she should have started like that she
should have started that way and then
taking it off and then no she should
have started her whole streaming career
that way and then when she puts makeup
on instead of what would she have had
the following justice but then you would
know people are there for your pursue no
one's ever because she turned from
latina to white that's true
she looks Asian like the Japanese girl
really yeah look at little guys do you
look more Asian than that
you do look she looks more Latino yeah
she looks like uh she looks like a
light-skinned Latina girl that likes
anime yeah yeah so then this just
started a whole bunch of hate in her
comments like why ugly and like because
she has like ten year olds in her
exactly that's what a lot of people are
saying it's like these people comment
and they're nutless you know why it's
cuz these boys were whacking off and
they're getting ready and they're like
oh but yeah drink this entire stream she
ended up doing her makeup and fixing her
hair so she looked good at the end of it
but that's [ __ ] up big guy
they act like she looks like Roseanne I
know I mean like it's a huge I feel like
she just did something that we all do
cuz if we show up with no makeup people
are like are you sick okay like this is
me but I just don't have makeup on you
know yeah I do have this theory though
the reason why girls don't look so
healthy with makeup off is because the
makeup every skin also you don't
and yeah yeah those are the makeup.you
net wrinkles if you like when we were in
Hawaii the first day y'all look like you
didn't sleep right but then at the end
of the trip you guys look like super
[ __ ] vibrant very beautiful thank you
guys are glowing - glowy no the guy he
just turned chocolate yeah we ended up
looking very I get I always try to stay
out of the Sun and get more like put my
like lighter makeup on well you have a
turn really dark I want to see here your
really dark my kid pictures are like on
like african-american yeah so a lot of
people a lot of women on switch they
started supporting pokiman mommy
yeah would you like to read she's still
pretty though what the [ __ ] it's like
pretty girls being pretty well yeah but
the whole point it's like they're just
showing their makeup free face how
[ __ ] up is that though that they have
to like make a statement like that's
just like this I will say this though I
will say this so I done it once on my
Instagram I post a no makeup and makeup
and all the girls were like [ __ ] yeah
thank you for this because they put you
in a light where they're like oh like
you know like you're perfect or whatever
and then when you show your
vulnerabilities you know guys [ __ ]
hate it but I don't I don't hate that
mainly guys are hating maybe guys that
have never had a girlfriend cuz if
you've ever had a girlfriend
exactly that was some of the comments
especially if you live with them so it's
like we've never seen eggs bunch of
virgins in the comments are very sad
upset you never saw five o'clock shadow
here I don't know one get laser baby I
don't have that [ __ ] before I've seen
that [ __ ] my mom to do my mom's is
[ __ ] late twelve o'clock after
menopause you start getting facial hair
more and stuff yeah Laser beep I don't
know I feel like I've vlog without
makeup all the time I can't remember the
last time I've logged with makeup like I
always do my vlogs without makeup cuz
I'm lazy and cuz I'm like um blogs are
more open and real say Marius if you're
here for a vlog this is real life yeah
yeah but I also do admire Kourt like you
like I admire girls that for them
they're like this is what I like and I'd
like to present myself this way and I'm
gonna maintain it this with like we have
another friend of Rica who you'll never
see without makeup and I think that's
tight too I wish it could be both
without having it be a statement right
yeah like you wear makeup or dolly or
makeup why's it got to be like a
statement yeah I hate that I think those
girls are much more critiqued and valued
based off of law yeah sure it's pies are
a lot of girls do their whole careers
are just looks
yeah but then but in most most of your
guys's things is you have a skill so you
don't rely on only your looks to like
make money we're a lot of other women do
like that's just their only thing that
they got that's sure so that's the
typecast himself
yeah but then if they you know sometimes
they get out of that and then they build
a skill and then they can till old age
you have like Betty White's and all that
stuff like they can survive but then I
think that's kind of where it gets
tricky for women yeah sucks huh yeah we
could be ugly as [ __ ] as long as we're
skilled we could stay in the limelight
stupid guys so here's another pose she
looks the same it does look the same no
it's the same oh yeah
that's just her without makeup makeup
yeah she's pretty good without me go all
these guys are really pretty yeah I'll
have even complexion what even sucks -
are they using filters yeah that they're
probably using filters and that right
lighting
oh yeah the bright lady they bought the
ranch to post a picture with no makeup
on it is for me at least I could say
that like I vlog without makeup probably
like three times in my life that's about
it and that's why your Instagram story
without makeup but now they added those
filters that I'm like addicted to
because I'm like oh I look so pretty no
Rihanna one is like on point like if you
if I have like the diamond that's like
my go-to it's like makeup takes work but
filters don't take any work of course
I'm gonna use the filter I started
putting lotion on my face looking great
yep I'm on a skincare routine lotion or
moisturizer so I got face wash three
different kinds one is clay one is this
dislike clay your fancy just put me on a
program just like you have to do this
[ __ ] and then after I do the dab toner
okay and then I have this little lotion
thing and I put it on and she's like
then now your skin looks nice thank you
it's been the second day
[Music]